[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag à spécial
élections municipales les français ont
la parole pendant toute la campagne on
va tenter de comprendre quelles sont vos
préoccupations au quotidien avec vos
remarques et notre sondage sur nos
réseaux sociaux et puis bien sûr notre
débat aujourd'hui on va parler pollution
de l'air dans les villes et dans les
campagnes de france avec nos invités sur
ce plateau
gilles dixsaut médecin généraliste et
président de la fondation du souffle
face à vous olivier blond président de
l'association respire ainsi que nicolas
malleval militants écologistes de la
génération future bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france presque
cinq ans après la coop 21 à paris les
voyants sont toujours au rouge pour la
france alors que le chef de l'état lui
multiplie les discours et affiche de
grandes ambitions
le pays n'a quasiment atteint aucun de
ses objectifs en 2010 huit émissions de
gaz à effet de serre transports
bâtiments consommation d'énergie peut
mieux faire
en déplacement à chamonix la semaine
dernière emmanuel macron a lancé
l'office français pour la biodiversité
le chef de l'état qui a parlé du combat
du siècle écoutés
ce sera le combat ni fier celui de notre
capacité à inventer mais nouvelle
manière de vivre d'habiter de faire
durable
je crois que ce combat du siècle nous
pouvons le relever et nous avons décidé
de le relever dans notre pays
et même si ces combats du siècle il
impose l'impatience il impose la
détermination
il impose d'agir vite et voilà donc pour
la déclaration d' emmanuel macron ce
sera le combat du siècle il faut de la
détermination a dit emmanuel macron
gilles dixsaut vous êtes biologiste et
non pas médecin généraliste et santé
publique
commencez vous de cette déclaration il
ya toujours des grandes déclarations
mais finalement on a l'impression que
les actes ne suivent pas derrière le
problème d'abord c'est de savoir de quoi
on parle
est ce qu'on parle d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre would you do de polluants
et d'émissions de polluants
c'est sale c'est ça le gros problème
parce que on fait de grandes de grandes
annonces sur la diminution des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre essentiellement
le co2 mais on oublie les autres mais on
oublie de dire en même temps que
diminuer le co2 c'est un facteur
d'augmentation de la pollution par
derrière
donc il faut prendre le problème de
manière globale et pas seulement nous
parler de co2 la coupe 21 c'était un peu
centré sur le sur le co2 le co2 mais
c'est un à confondre avec les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre pour le design
le co2 est un gaz à effet de serre parmi
d'autres et c'est un gaz à effet de
serre à longue durée d'action mais il y
en a d'autres qui a le méthane qui est
un gaz à effet de serre qui est à un peu
moins longue durée d'action mais qui est
beaucoup plus efficients en termes de
gaz à effet serre et puis y en a encore
d'autres comme le protoxyde d azote qui
lui 298 x plus efficients que le co2
mais on oublie d'en parler donc quand
vous dites hull et les objectifs de la
cob l'ancien finalement ne parlait que
de gaz à effet de serre il en manque
dans la liste en termes de santé
publique en termes de santé publique les
gaz à effet de serre che direct c'est
pas un problème de santé publique c'est
un problème de réchauffement climatique
mais ça n'est pas du tout un problème de
santé publique non plus il ya
volontairement une confusion qui est
faite entre les deux entre gaz à effet
de serre pour lesquelles on nous parle
de pollution mais c'est une pollution à
long terme pour le climat et on en
oublie parle pas de la pollution qui a
un effet sur la santé et qui est tout à
fait autre chose
olivier blond vous qui êtes spécialiste
de la santé des français justement ces
gaz à effet de serre ne sont pas donc
dangereux en soi pour pour la
respiration des citoyens ce sont les
particules fines qui sont qui sont mis
en cause pour sur la santé
spécifiquement la pollution de l'air
elle est protéiforme
elle a de nombreuses composantes ya des
particules il ya des gaz avec des
particules qui viennent du trafic
automobile il y en a qui viennent des
activités agricoles jeunes à qui se
recombinent rex et c'est une chimiste
super compliqué mais d'ailleurs mais il
faut bien dire c'est que tous ensemble
ils sont responsables d'une crise
sanitaire majeure
déjà aujourd'hui en france chaque année
entre 48 et 60 5000 morts
alors donc c'est l'équivalent d'une
ville qui disparaissent chaque année à
cause de cette pollution
et face à cette crise sanitaire
effectivement les réactions elles sont
extrêmement faibles extrêmement lente à
se déployer sur le terrain et c'est
choquant d'autant plus qu' on a des
moyens pour réagir et on a aussi des
comparaisons c'est à dire que la lutte
contre l'insécurité routière par exemple
qui tu es à cinq fois plus
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quelques décennies
eh ben on a vu que quand gouvernement
s'en saisit et bain avec des clips de
sensibilisation 1 classe ceinture de
sécurité est obligatoire avec plein de
choses on arrive à la diminuer on a vu
que l'alcoolisme ou le tabagisme est
bien avec des grandes campagnes avec des
moyens et bas on peut diminuer pas pas
tout résoudre en taxant notamment les
cigarettes
peut-être mais c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
fâche aussi les français c'est être mais
au moins ça marche
et là il se passe rien il se passe rien
du tout quand vous dit rien il ya des
mesures néanmoins qui ont été prises par
le par le gouvernement d incitation à
acheter des véhicules électriques des
chèques énergie pour remplacer son
système d'isolement dans les maisons
tout ça ne contribue pas seul on voit
vraiment on n'est pas du tout à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
encore une fois qui est une crise de
santé publique des gens qui meurent tous
les jours 48 selon le
la santé publique c'est des chiffres
officiels c'est pas une association mort
prématurée justement lieu à des gens ne
le comprennent pas en général ils
pensent que la pollution de l'air est
bon on va voir d'une crise d'asthme
irritations du nez de la gorge et ça
c'est pas ça le problème avec la
pollution de l'air l'enjeu c'est les avc
donc les problèmes cardiovasculaires
parce que la pollution quand elle est
très petit
elle rentre dans les poumons une fois
qu'elle est dans les poumons elle rentre
dans la circulation sanguine et elle va
hériter les veines les artères
le coeur est là ça fait ça fait des avc
ça fait des infarctus et c'est ça qui
tue les chiffres
pardon les chiffres de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
ils sont terribles dans le monde un
tiers des avc sont causées par la
pollution de l'air ça veut dire que vous
connaissez tous autour de vous quelqu'un
qui a eu ce genre de problème qui est
peut-être tombé dans la rue casgrain
pour apprendre dans son état et un tiers
des cas eh bien c'est la pollution de
l'air et on ne sait rien aujourd'hui et
c'est choquant troisième cause de
mortalité vous vous vous confirmer après
après la cigarette et l'alcool
absolument et même selon certaines
études c'est la première ça dépend
comment est-ce qu'on est contre mais
enfin c'est majeur en tout cas ces neuf
mois d'espérance de vie en moins pour
les parisiens à titre de comparaison
c'est les grandes villes qui sont les
plus touchés nicolas malleval vous qui
êtes jeunes vous êtes sensibilisé
évidemment à ce problème de la pollution
de l'air qu'ils ont voulu faire pour
améliorer la situation
est ce qu'on pourrait faire c'est tout
d'abord mettre en oeuvre un certain
nombre de mesures vis-à-vis de la
protection des riverains haché nation
futur on a mis en évidence la présence
d'un certain nombre de pesticides dans
l'air que ça soit à la vous faire des
campagnes évidemment oui à la fois dans
les campagnes et des grandes villes
effectivement parce qu'il ya des mesures
servent en fait à paris bordeaux ou
lille par exemple et on a mis en
évidence un certain nombre de pesticides
qui sont présents dans l'air à skis est
vraiment inquiétant c'est que parmi ces
pesticides on a une forte une forte
majorité de molécules qui sont cmr donc
qu'ils sont à des molécules soient
cancérigènes mutagènes c'est à dire
qu'ils vont
qui vont altérer l'adn ou alors
reprotoxiques qui vont pouvoir altérer
notamment le développement du foetus et
des molécules également suspecté est
perturbateur endocrinien a donc cédé
molécules qui ne sont pas neutres à et
on sait très bien que de manière un peu
basique on respire un nombre de fois
très très important dans une journée et
que c'est des petites quantités qui vont
s'additionner
en plus d'autres facteurs qui vont être
l'alimentation où l'eau à aix et donc
une exposition qui peut être très très
forte
gilles dixsaut est-ce que c'est pire
qu'avant finalement on c'est vrai qu'on
nous fait peur à ce qu'eads de réelle
étude qui démontre l'impact de ces
pesticides à proximité des habitations
ou honda ou delà des particules fines
dans l'air est ce qu'il ya des études
qui montrent le réel impact sur la santé
aujourd'hui
alors on a un certain nombre d'études
vous citiez tout à l'heure les études de
santé publique france qui évaluer
l'effet des pm 2,5 c'est à dire pas
toute la pollution mais la pollution
représenté par les particules fines 1 48
mille morts par an si on ajoute d'autres
pathologies que celles qui ont été
analysées d'autres études arrivent à 70
mille morts par an dans qu'on est dans
des ordres de grandeur de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de morts commencent
à les compter aujourd'hui on les
comptait pas vendre l'exemple ne
comptait pas avant et on n'a pas ce
qu'on n'avait pas jirel et les
techniques d'analysé épidémiologique
pour le faire et puis on commence aussi
à compter en termes de dépenses je
rappelle que le le le fall étude du
sénat de la commission d'étude du sénat
avait trouvé un coût de la pollution
atmosphérique de 103 milliards 3
milliards
un peu plus de 100 milliards d'euros par
an le rapport de la cour des comptes
dit à peu près la même chose et nous en
matière de pathologie respiratoire on
avait fait une évaluation des coudes sur
les cas émergents s'il ya des cas qui
surviennent chaque année liées à la
pollution atmosphérique en terme de
maladies respiratoires seulement on
était entre 1 et 2 milliards d'euros par
an pour les cas émergents c'est à dire
qui s'ajoutaient chaque année aux
dépenses de santé alors on a un chiffre
aussi sur les émissions des particules
qui sont nocifs pour la santé
toute particule confondues 1254 kilos
tonnes en 1990 où le voyait à l'écran
851 en 2015 la source et le centre
interprofessionnel technique d'études de
pollution atmosphérique
ces chiffres sont contestables olivier
blanc vous êtes d'accord où je pose la
question à à gilles dixsaut oui ils sont
contestables parce que effectivement le
site non non ça n'a pas baissé en fait
alors en fait on est d'accord gillet -
la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on mesure
si on mesure les plus grosses particules
c'est ce qu'on mesure depuis des
dizaines d'années parce qu'avant on ne
savait pas faire autrement
eh ben on voit une diminution
si on ne mesurait les plus petites
particules les plus nocives donc qu'ils
sont beaucoup plus nocives
alors on voit une augmentation donc en
fait on est face à un double discours si
on regarde les grosses bah oui ça va
mieux si on regarde les petites ben non
le problème est en train de s'aggraver
sous nos yeux
notamment à cause des nouvelles
motorisations dont on pense à priori
qu'elles vont être meilleurs
les nouvelles voitures polluent sont
plus sont plus nocives notamment les et
les nouveaux diesels
alors expliquez nous pourquoi gilles
dixsaut vous êtes aussi d'accord avec ça
en fait c'est la façon de calculer qui
avantage évidemment les industriels on
prend plutôt les meilleurs chiffres pour
vendre des voitures ça fait tout à fait
parce qu'autrefois la pollution c'était
une pollution particulaire comme l'a dit
olivier de grosses particules c'était le
chauffage au charbon c'était les jeux
comme motive à vapeur c'était les 403
diesel tout ce qui fut mais c'était de
la grosses particules maintenant les
technologies moteurs ont fait que on a
des filtres à particules par exemple
mais le filtre à particules et va capter
essentiellement les grosses les agrégats
de particules de dire que ça va pas ça
ne va pas fumer mais ça va laisser
passer des particules ultrafines de
l'ordre de 100 nanomètres et terre 0-1
conte et ses particules à ce sont les
plus dangereuses pour la santé
les véhicules essence de son aussi
problématique les nouvelles générations
de véhicules essence parce que les
véhicules essence à injection directe
pourra aussi émettre des particules
ultrafines en quantité au moins égale à
celle des diesels et on sait que sur ces
types de particules les filtres à
particules sont très peu efficaces donc
il ya pas que le problème du diesel il
ya le problème de la circulation des
véhicules thermiques en général donc
quoi il faut il vaut mieux acheter un
véhicule électrique pour essayer je
répondrai que ça fait plus de vingt ans
que je roule dans des véhicules à gaz et
c'est une autre façon de régler le
problème même si c'est un véhicule
thermique 1 qui n'est pas très répandu
en france france mais ailleurs c'est
très répandu
c'est à dire dans quel pays bas prenez
les prenez les pays bas par exemple
c'est pas loin prenez la belgique prenez
l'italie a plus loin l'accord la corée
sur les véhicules à gaz
prenez ben parce que parce qu'en france
il ya un lobby qu'est le lobby du diesel
qui a tout fait pour bloquer le véhicule
passe et tout est là on parlait des
engagements tenus ou pas de la france en
matière de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique on a quelques éléments de
réponse avec guy marosi on en parle
après pour la période 2015 2018 la
stratégie nationale bas carbone avait
fixé une limite d'émission de 442
mégatonnes de gaz à effet de serre par
an soit 1768 mégatonnes au total fin
2018 nous en étions à 10 830 mégatonnes
soit 3 5% de plus que prévu on pourrait
se dire que le gouvernement aurait prévu
de rattraper ce retard pour la période
2010 9 2023 mais surprise le 20 janvier
la stratégie nationale bas carbone non
seulement ne rectifié pas le tir mais
fixer des objectifs encore moins
ambitieux qu'auparavant presque 6% de
plus que ce qui était prévu en 2015
mais malgré tout les tak ont toujours
parvenir à atteindre les 40 %
d'émissions en moins en 2030 avec une
moyenne annuelle de près de 3% par an
alors que la tendance des 15 dernières
années est presque deux fois moins forte
et encore alors que la france s'était
engagée sur le facteur 4 c'est à dire à
diviser par quatre nos émissions à
horizon 2050 la loi énergie climat
adopté le 26 septembre dernier a
remplacé cet objectif déjà difficile à
atteindre par la neutralité carbone
c'est à dire zéro émissions nettes
en clair nous ne mettrions pas de gaz à
effet de serre au delà de la capacité
d'absorption des puits carbone naturels
et artificiels
une intention louable sauf qu'à moins de
recouvrir la france de forêt et
d'inventer un système révolutionnaire de
stockage du co2
la neutralité carbone signifie non pas
diviser par quatre nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mais les divise
et par huit et en commençant maintenant
cela signifie un rythme des réductions
des émissions presque trois fois et demi
supérieur à ce que nous avons connu
depuis 2005
alors la france arrive t elle à
concilier capitalisme et écologiques
comme emmanuel macron le déclarait
possible à chamonix il y a quelques
jours
et bien pour le moment la réponse est
non alors la réponse est non on ne peut
pas considérer capitalisme écologie
nicolas malleval une réaction est ce que
d'ailleurs ce que les chiffres de
chiffres sont corrects france est
exactement de ces chiffres là puisque
l'on traite particulièrement la question
des pesticides
maintenant je vais revenir aussi sur sur
la question des actions qui sont faites
pour la protection la protection des
populations en général on peut s'étonner
de certaines incohérences dans l'est
dans les choix qui sont faits parfois ce
qu'a annoncé my own accro à chamonix
justement pour protéger les zones
d'habitation ça c'est ça va dans le bon
sens non ça va dans le bon sens après il
faut toujours voir comment s'est mis en
place
effectivement mais pour pour un exemple
qui nous nous tient à coeur
on sait que le procès le faucard qui est
un pesticide particulièrement utilisé en
france dans un arrêté qui a été publié
le 27 décembre 2019 le l'état a voulu
mettre en place des zones de non
traitement donc des zones tampon entre
les chants les habitations mais la
distance n'est pas suffisante c'est nous
c'est ce que l'on pense et ce qui
corrobore un peu notre notre propos
c'est que cette distance vont jusqu'à 20
mètres en fonction des types de cultures
et des types de molécules utilisées
et justement pour ce procès le faut car
on a des on a déjà des mesures qui sont
mis en place pour la protection des
cultures en elle-même qui vont jusqu'à
un kilomètre de distance
donc il ya vraiment une incohérence
entre les entre les deux les deux
décisions
oui l'état qui minimisent alors que 79%
des français souhaitent la mise en place
d'une zone de tampon justement entre les
zones d'habitation et les agriculteurs
au salon de l'agriculture d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron a promis peut-être
d'indemniser les agriculteurs par des
trucs at il dit un jeu le site pour
permettre aux agriculteurs d'avoir des
revenus
on le voit on essaie on l'a vu il faut
aussi contenter les personnes qui est
qui qui polluent sans le vouloir
vraiment parce qu'il faut aussi que
finalement l'industrie
puisse puisse fonctionner olivier blond
je reviens sur les chiffres de notre de
notre reporter est-ce qu'on peut
concilier écologie et capitalisme selon
vous à mon avis c'est possible ça reste
à prouver concrètement parce que
justement en france on n'y est pas mais
ce que je trouve un petit peu constant
finalement dans le discours politique
qu'on entend sur le réchauffement
climatique c'est qu'effectivement on
fait des grandes déclarations
on se souvient tous de jacques chirac
que la maison brûle et on regarde
ailleurs c'était quand même il ya
presque vingt ans et est rien rien ne la
suive derrière à petit une certaine
manière autant il ya une une dette
publique en milliards d'euros autant il
ya une dette écologique maintenant on
accumule des retards et puis ce sera les
générations futures peut-être on sait
pas qui sent qu'ils sont en arrangeront
et effectivement c'est choquant ce que
je trouve intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
que si on peut déplorer
je trouve une action globale sur ces
sujets là haut niveau de l'état les
municipalités s'empare des sujets alors
la pollution de l'air on voit que c'est
un enjeu municipal à habitable j'habite
à paris
c'est le sujet de très nombreuses
discussions alors on est d'accord n'est
pas d'accord comme il faut dans ce cas
c'est un vrai objet de débat mais en
tout cas des gens s'emparent du sujet
les maires de grenoble 2 lyon 2 2
bordeaux sont part de ces sujets là et
en fait ce qui est presque étonnant
c'est que les mères en france sont en
avance sont à l'avant garde du combat
pour l'écologie le bien-être des
populations et l'état qui est pourtant
normalement en charge des fonctions
régaliennes dont la protection la
population eh ben il est à la traîne il
parle et puis il laisse aux autres le
soin d'agir et pour quelles raisons
selon vous c'est toujours cette histoire
de déconnexion finalement des réalités
ou pas oui très clairement surtout sur
la pollution
c'est une question de deux quotidiens
jeudi rond on sent la pollution quand on
avi tous les jours on sent quand on a
nos enfants qui vont à l'école et qu'il
ya des crises d'asthme qui dont le
nombre augmente tous les jours quand on
voit les petits qui tous quand on les
amène le long de la nationale états ont
peut voir tout ça et en tant que citoyen
il est plus facile de d'interpeller le
maire ou la mer alors que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui basse bon voilà le pouvoir
central reste un petit peu indifférent
et malheureusement et emmanuel macron
qui avait un ministre de l'écologie qui
a d'ailleurs démissionné justement par
rapport à cette inaction que vous
dénoncez de l'état regarde et je ne veux
plus me mentir je veux pas donner
l'illusion que ma présence au
gouvernement signifie qu'on est à la
hauteur sur ces enjeux là l état n'est
pas à la hauteur de ces enjeux à gilles
dixsaut un commentaire en tant que
citoyen bien sûr alors le commentaire je
reviendrai sur ce qu'a dit olivier tout
à l'heure les maires agissent
effectivement mais je dirais que
peut-être les maires sont plus éloignés
des lobbys et que que les
administrations centrales et les
ministres niveau en tant que médecin il
ya eu un collectif de médecins qui a
alerté aussi intense que ses problèmes
de santé publique en tout à fait nous
faisons partie de ceux que de ce
collectif absolument un donc vous vous
demandez aussi au gouvernement d'agir
comme anquetil agir plus vite puisque ça
coûte alors aussi beaucoup d'argent et
les français ne veulent pas être taxés
alors qu'en d'abord pour agir plus vite
oui d'abord il faudrait que les les
pouvoirs publics au niveau central est
une meilleure connaissance de ce qu'est
la pollution atmosphérique et par
d'autre chose que du cod de voile a
donné la confusion comme les sept
associations cette confusion est fait je
dirais volontairement par un certain
nombre de lobbies et aussi par les
administrations et quand on a quand on a
eu l'occasion d'avoir des rencontres
avec des ministères dont le ministère de
l'écologie on s'est aperçu que les
responsables du ministère de l'écologie
connaissez très très mal la pollution
atmosphérique la vraie sert pas les gaz
à effet de serre la pollution
atmosphérique qui a un effet sur la
santé ils connaissent très très mal ce
que ce sont les véhicules qu'ils sont
premier mis en cause on essaie de
freiner rares chi de ce qui était le
plus nocif pour la santé puisque c'est
vraiment la santé des français qui est
en jeu au delà du réchauffement
climatique les véhicules en premier lieu
le bâtiment les industries tout dépend
où on se trouve
ces salles pour le fond du problème dans
les grandes métropoles comme paris
ce sont certainement les véhicules qui
sont à mettre en premier et puis je
dirais aussi tout dépend de la saison en
hiver quand vous avez du chauffage au
fuel dans les grandes villes quand vous
avez du chauffage au bois alors ça c'est
une calamité le chauffage au bois dans
dans pas forcément dans les grandes
villes mais dans les périphéries des
grandes villes vous avez beaucoup de
chauffage au bois qui est extrêmement
polluant parce que on n'a rien fait
depuis fort longtemps pour améliorer le
chauffage au bois
or on sait faire du chauffage au bois
propre ou quasiment propre et on a aussi
toujours le bois qui s'est toujours le
bois mais on peut penser éliminé on sait
éliminer les et les fumées vous avez le
bois qui fument et qui sent le qui sent
le feu de bois
c'est parce que vous avez des composés
organiques volatils dedans qui sont pas
très sympathique et vous avez des
vallées alpines entières qui sont
pollués en permanence par le chauffage
au bois est aussi par les véhicules
parce que vous avez tous les camions qui
circulent alors quelle est la part de la
quelle est la part de l'autre j'aurais
que les deux s'ajoutent et que on peut
pas être tiré sur l'un plus que sur
l'autre tout dépend de l'endroit où on
est et du contenu de la pollution qu'on
respire les le problème des pesticides
également que la malle valls est votre
spécialité
on note aussi de plus en plus de cas
keith de personnes qui sont malades ou
qui ont des problèmes à cause de ces
pistes ici vous l'avez constaté où il ya
un certain nombre de syndromes qui sont
maintenant on sait que c'est dieu aux
pesticides
là où on a un véritable problème dans le
domaine c'est qu'aujourd'hui aucune
réglementation ne fixe la présence de
pesticides dans l'air que ce soit en
terme de concentration ou en termes de
molécules en tant que tel a donc il ya
une méconnaissance de sa les études sont
faites un peu sur la base du volontariat
avec des méthodes qui sont qui ne sont
pas harmonisées donc une difficulté de
comparer aussi les résultats entre les
régions ça soit une région viticole ou
une région plus une grande ville une
grande métropole a donc sept jours de
quantifier réellement cette exposition
elle risque qui est lié à cette
exposition et sur la qualité de l'air
paradoxalement olivier blond plus il
fait doux - l'air est pollué si j'ai
bien compris
alors il ya des pièges en fait on va
essayer d'y voir clair parce qu'on a
bien été doux il ya eu moins de
chauffage donc moins de moins de
diminution de l'univers effectivement ça
peut jouer et ce qui est sûr c'est que
la pollution daf la présence de pics de
pollution
elle est tributaire de phénomènes
météorologiques comme des anticyclones
par exemple qu'ils vont faire une sorte
de chape de plomb autour de la ville ou
de la zone qui vont donc permettre à la
pollution de se concentrer de plus en
plus ce qui est paradoxal c'est concret
et finalement ce qui est paradoxal c'est
que malgré ces variétés de
météorologiques on sait que chaque année
il y aura trois pics de pollution ils
reviennent d'année en équipements 1 en
décembre pendant justement les fortes
éléments où on a besoin de se chauffer
donc autour de décembre 1 au moment du
printemps avec les activités dépendent à
gérer et de pesticides et un troisième
en plein été avec les épisodes
caniculaires qui sont associés à des
épisodes de pics d'ozone
donc chaque année ça revient on sait pas
toujours exactement c'est ça sera le 15
décembre où le 30 mai mais on connait
perianes c'est tellement prévisible que
aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu on arrive
sur des piques et qu'on a l'impression
d'avoir une sorte d'improvisation
gouvernementales ou préfectorales
parfois sur les mesures à prendre
est ce que oui ou non
on va passer ancrée terre ou pas que
c'est que c'est vraiment c'est pas
sérieux c'est vraiment pas sérieux parce
qu'encore une fois chaque année depuis
dix ans et malheureusement dans les
années à venir
on sait que ces pics de pollution vont
survenir donc on pourrait les prendre
des mesures et les anticiper on continue
bien sûr ce débat sur la politique du
gouvernement en matière de lutte contre
la pollution et le réchauffement
climatique
on va également parlé de la fermeture du
premier réacteur de la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim c'était il ya
quelques jours a tout de suite
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro et
donc des pays du sud qui n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur niveau de richesse
d'avant la crise vous avez la grèce et
aussi lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on
a pu avoir au niveau de la zone euro n'a
pas réussi à sortir de la crise mais
c'est à dire qu'on vous parle de la
baisse du chômage au portugal ou en
espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous ces pays là et notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré 350 je ne sais pas
qui est la locomotive de l'europe en
tout cas ne croyez pas que ce soit la
france
[Musique]
je
à
mais
[Musique]
l'europe la france aujourd'hui on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'y passe les
chiffres sont bons
personne n'est content c'est à dire que
la désindustrialisation de la france
très très fort depuis 20 ans s'est
traduite par des fermeture de milliers
d'usinés
peu de gens osent le dire mais je le dis
il ya un retour en allemagne depuis une
dizaine d'années d'un mépris pour la
france parce que les allemands n'ont pas
compris qu'un pays adultes se laissent
des industrialisés comme nous l'avons
fait et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
depuis 50 ans on est en déficit que la
conjoncture soit bonne ou mauvaise
devant encore vous dire que vous vous
comparer à l'allemagne je ne rentre pas
dans cette approche des gens qui lie
sous-estiment l'allemagne et l'allemagne
est en fait tant son insertion dans
l'économie mondiale dans la même
position que le japon donc l'allemagne
n'est pas foutu est donc la clé ça
pourrait être
l'entente entre la france et l allemand
la question reste sur la table dans la
mesure où ça fait dix ans que les
allemands bloc toutes les salles
historiques
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec que gilles
dixsaut président de la fondation du
souffle olivier blond président de
l'association respirer et nicolas
malleval militants écologistes
générations futures c'était une promesse
de campagne à des manuels macron le
réacteur numéro 1 de la centrale
nucléaire de fessenheim a été débranchée
vendredi soir une mise à l'arrêt
controversé absurde et coûteuse selon
les habitants les salariés et les élus
du aura regardé voilà on a sacrifié sur
l'autel de way sur un autel politique là
cette centrale de fessenheim
les deux réacteurs de la centrale d'air
là on dit c'est la pub est central de
france sauf que effectivement l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire à qaïm dit et répété
plusieurs fois que c'est une des
centrales est plus sûr de france donc
voilà donc d'où l'incompréhension aussi
de l'ensemble de nos de nos de nos
concitoyens à l'ensemble des élus
l'ensemble des salariés et puis sept en
huit ans ce sont 700 millions d'euros
qui ont été investis dans fessenheim 700
millions d'euros
et tant mieux parce que on n'aurait pas
accepté que l'exploitation de fessenheim
se fasse dans des conditions qui ne
soient pas le maximum du standard de la
sûreté la sécurité dans le nucléaire
mais imaginez ces 700 millions d'euros
qui sont à gâcher qui sont jetés par la
fenêtre sur le dos d'un compromis
politiciens et et d'une promesse
électorale
absurde olivier blouin est ce une
absurdité d'avoir fermé en tout cas le
réacteur numéro 1 sachant que là
le nucléaire et pollue pas beaucoup
finalement vous avez ou pas alors c'est
toujours un peu très compliqué qui ont
piqué 1 le nucléaire propre en termes de
co2 encore que vaille vraiment faire des
calculs pendant compte d'extraction
l'acheminement leur traitement et c'est
à ça donc les chiffres sont pas aussi
beau conte qu'on nous le dit mais
surtout le problème du nucléaire c'est
quand même un problème de transparence
de 2,2 pas cité de lobby ultra puissant
et oui c'est vrai c'est vrai que la
décision là elle peut elle peut choquer
il est compliqué par endroits mais le
fonctionnement global de la filière
nucléaire en france est choquant est
compliquée et ultra souvent sonné c'est
des milliards et des milliards qui vont
pour renflouer les caisses d'areva
esterra de ça depuis des années c'est le
père qui ne qui ne marche pas et qui
encore une fois qui s'est souvent ce
n'était pas sur la pollution là on est
sur des problèmes économiques de retard
de vous parliez de pair le cos a un coût
aussi pour les français l'énergie le
nucléaire est quand même une énergie qui
est à bakou enfin qui est moins cher qu
que deux énergies renouvelables par
exemple
voilà justement alors justement on est
en train et c'est une bonne nouvelle de
mon point de vue ou non parce qu'on
appelle une combe en ciseaux c'est à
dire que les coûts de l'énergie
nucléaire augmente à cause notamment du
fiasco de le p r qui est chaque jour de
plus en plus cher et les coûts de
l'énergie renouvelables notamment le
solaire sont en train de diminuer donc
il ya ces deux courbes des prix qui se
croisent aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui il
est plus simple plus rapide plus
efficace et moins coûteux de construire
du photovoltaïque que de construire du
nucléaire c'est pour ça que voilà il
faut il faut aussi avoir une vision à
long terme se dire que on est face à des
choix industriels qui nous engage pour
les décennies à venir
et peut-être c'est plus intelligent de
construire une filière du photovoltaïque
d'aisé venerque on pourra en plus
exporter facilement dans le monde entier
plutôt que de défendre ce truc qui
aujourd'hui ne marche plus malheureuse
n'a exporté du nucléaire mais on a vu ce
que ça a donné ça marche
aujourd'hui gilles dixsaut est ce que le
problème finalement c'est
de la france c'est de ne pas avoir
suffisamment diversifié sa politique
énergétique
c'est sûrement le problème de la france
en a pas diversifier la politique
énergétique et on a surtout en france
bloquer le développement d'un certain
nombre de filières qui démarré de façon
tout à fait correct on a on se souvient
que le l'éolien par exemple en france il
ya un certain nombre d'années avait
démarré et puis toutes les sociétés se
sont un peu effondré parce que elles
n'ont pas trouvé de marché en france
et parce que rossi en france ça fait du
bruit les gens spring oui mais il y
avait on a créé des complications
administratives épouvantable pour
l'éolien ce qui fait que ça ne s'est pas
tout à fait développer comme on aurait
pu le souhaiter mais la france était à
la pointe et maintenant elle ne l'est
plus parce que parce que on n'a pas
développé le marché en france pour le
photovoltaïque aussi en france on n'a
pas développé aussi rapidement que par
exemple en allemagne où ils ont pourtant
un ensoleillement qui est moins bon
qu'en france mais ils ont développé
beaucoup plus le photovoltaïque que chez
nous là même qui marche toujours au
charbon est ce que c'est quand
l'allemagne marche toujours au charbon
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils ont
supprimé le nucléaire ils ont réduit le
nucléaire donc ils sont passés au
charbon mais il brille il pollue plus et
pollue plus en terme de pollution est
d'ailleurs un effet sur la santé c'est à
dire la position particulière du no2 et
aussi en termes de production de co2
mais c'était c'est un choix qui a été
fait on supprime le nucléaire pour le
remplacer par du charbon mais entrant
progressivement ils sont en train de
passer vers des énergies renouvelables
nicolas malleval vous parlez des zones à
risque à côté des
les zones agricoles où il ya des
épandages il ya aussi le problème de ces
usines classées seveso où on l'a vu
récemment à lusigny brizola près d'un
seul il ya eu beaucoup de de particules
et ce gros nuages qui s'en est dégagé ça
aussi c'est un problème de santé
publique finalement ah bah oui oui
clairement c'est un problème de santé
publique et puis surtout on a
l'impression d'un manque clair de
transparence de certaines entreprises
qui sont situées au milieu de viviers de
populations qui sont comme on le voit à
rouen qui sont énormes a donc un réel
problème sanitaire qui se pose ici que
ça soit au niveau des réglementations
qui doivent bien encadrer l'utilisation
de certaines matières lac salé cox imité
juste même la proxinvest la proximité
pour une zone d'habitation est ce que
c'est c'est le même problème que les
agriculteurs et les habitations
effectivement la proximité peut poser
question est effectivement c'est c'est
la même chose même si on peut on peut
quand même se dire qu'il ya moins de
chance que des matières toxiques dans
une usine high au contact de populations
qui sont proches dans des endroits
fermés des ondes mais effectivement le
problème se pose tout autant
oui ça fait peur aux français olivier
blond ce nuage toxique
on va écouter les abbés de bornes qui a
parlé la semaine dernière justement sur
les mesures qui seront prises dorénavant
par par le gouvernement écouter la rue
alors si vous habitez à proximité du
musée n'est qu' un incendie
immédiatement l'industriel devra faire
connaître les produits qui sont en cause
la nature des produits et les quantités
il devra aussi être capable d'éclairer
l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics mais
aussi des riverains sur l'épaule dans
qui peuvent être et nice qui nous permet
de faire mettre en place la surveillance
environnementale instantanée et de moyen
terme
on met en oeuvre quand on a ce type
d'accident alors on s'en souvient de la
polémique après cet incendie à lui
brisant ne connaissez pas vraiment là la
teneur des po lyon qui avait été stocké
dans cette usine au gouvernement à un
peu pataugé ça c'est quand même
on est quand même au 21ème siècle
comment ça c'est qu'on n'arrive pas à
savoir ce qui est parti dans l'air
finalement aujourd'hui on a un peu plus
de précision mais est ce que est ce que
ça aussi c'est insuffisant en matière de
prévention
très clairement ce qui s'est passé à
lubrizol c'est un fiasco complet en
terme de gestion d'une catastrophe
technologique
nous on respire on a créé un groupe
local qui s'est fortement impliqué là
dessus que calé en justice pour demander
la vérité la transparence qu'on a
toujours pas sur un somme de 2 2 points
et ce qui est terrifiant c'est l'ampleur
de la catastrophe ces marées noires en
plein coeur d'une ville de 100000
habitants et une agglomération de
plusieurs centaines d'amis c'est dix
mille tonnes c'est vraiment ccc le
l'erika au milieu d'une ville et donc
moi il ya tellement de choses à raconter
là je je je je pouvais pas tout dire
mais une chose qui est frappante c'est
le fait que soit disant il ya une
surveillance ces sites seveso seuil haut
ans donc ils sont les voilà qui sont les
1200 sites industriels les plus
dangereux potentiellement il ya eu des
dizaines d'inspection du site et aucune
n'a rien vu en gros pour laure et pour
résumer et ce n'est que après la
catastrophe que l' enquête judiciaire va
mettre en lumière tel et tel
dysfonctionnement dans le système d'
incendies dans le plan de sécurité dans
des points techniques essentielles et
qu'est ce que ça montre ça montre que
les inspections et ben elles ne servent
pas faire ce qu'elle devrait faire c'est
à dire un peu identifier les risques et
les empêcher et donc la ministre elle a
annoncé qu'on allait augmenter ce nombre
d'inspections ce qui est une bonne idée
parce qu'on les avait diminué pour
réduire les budgets donc on va en gros
les faire revenir au haut niveau initial
c'est que d'admiration on a installé un
exactement vida mais en fait c'est pas
ça qui va régler le problème en fait il
faut trouver une manière de d'inspecter
les sites industriels de manière
autonome et un petit peu incisives et
aujourd'hui on voit bien que c'est pas
le cas il ya des connivences et des
faiblesses dans les systèmes
d'évaluation qui
on a eu lubrizol sais que tu es comme la
deuxième fois que le site avait un
problème c'est qu'en 2013 est lui déjà
un gros accident
on a eu du boulot dole il ya en fait
presque tous les jours des accidents
dans les sites seveso bas et comment
faire pour empêcher qu'il ya un autre du
briol ailleurs aujourd'hui je trouve que
le gouvernement ne donne pas les bonnes
réponses
gilles dixsaut ce problème de
transparence vous êtes d'accord
oui c'est il ya un fiasco de
communication en plus dans cette affaire
lubrizol parce que on a expliqué à la
population que les dangers il y avait
plus de pollution or il suffisait de
circuler dans la ville de roanne pour
s'apercevoir qu'il y avait une odeur
absolument pestilentielles et on
expliquer aux habitants qu'il n'y avait
aucune pollution pourquoi la raison est
très simple c'est qu'on mesure et
certains polluants qui s'était dit
qu'ils sont les polluants réglementés et
on ne s'occupait pas de mesurer les
polluants qui sentait si mauvais c'est à
dire qu'il suffit effectivement de faire
un choix dans les polluants que l'on
mesure pour avoir les bons résultats
c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
et c'est comme ça qu'on peut toujours
dire que les choses s'améliorent fédé on
fait des analyses sur ceux ci s'est
décidé au départ d analyse finalement on
prend on prend on fait des analyses sur
les polluants réglementés nord les polos
réglementés ne sont pas du tout en
rapport avec une situation d' incendies
c'est ce sont des polluants réglementés
qui sont fondés sur une situation
normale je dirais et pas sur des
situations critiques comme celle là vous
parlez d'un sens dit merci pour cette
transition les incendies aussi sont
extrêmement néfaste pour la qualité de
l'air
j'en viens aux agriculteurs nicolas
malleval le fait de brûler
et les déchets verts par exemple est-ce
que ça aussi ça pollue l'atmosphère
évidemment ça pollue l'atmosphère sans
fin sans débat possible après à quelle
échelle journée c'est ce sont des
pratiques encore au jour ces des
pratiques courantes il faut qu'il se
sente illégale et qui représentent des
nuisances pour les voisins très forte
nous respirons reçoit régulièrement des
plaintes de gens qui sont désespérés
parce que leur voisin brûle de manière
régulière lors déchets végétaux mais ils
mettent par dessus en gros la poubelle
donc du plastique est illégal c'est
autorisé sur une certaine période où je
veux non non le bleu bruche le brûlage
de déchets végétaux en extérieur est
interdit en tout cas en ile de france et
dans le m 2 c'est certain et c'est
préfectorale mais en général c'est
interdit et ça ça reste dans les faits
parce que les gens sous-estiment
largement l'impact sanitaire que ça peut
avoir
et puis parce que ils n'ont pas envie la
légendaire c'est un petit peu ça après
quand les gens viennent les voir parfois
et des relations très tendues
les personnes qui se plaignent font face
à une hostilité et et voire parfois
après ceux des agressions on l'a vu
effectivement est ce que gilles dixsaut
il ya d'autres réflexes que les français
ont aujourd'hui qui pourrait être un
coup qui pourrait ne plus exister par
exemple vous parliez du chauffage de
bois par exemple il ya des gros qui sont
meilleurs que d'autres en tout cas en
termes d'environnement
tout à fait il faut pas mettre dans une
d'abord il ne faut pas utiliser de ce
qu'on appelle des foyers ouverts à la
bonne vieille cheminée
parce que d'abord ça un rendement
calorique est extrêmement faible
et deuxièmement parce que ça pollue
beaucoup plus donc toujours utiliser ce
qu'on appelle des foyers fermés sont les
inserts ou d'autres ou d'autres
équipements de ce type
la cheminée à foyer ouvert c'est une
catastrophe en termes de pollution
ensuite on ne met pas dans un appareil
de chauffage au bois n'importe quel bois
il faut des bois qui est à séchage
suffisant et il faut des bois qui ne
soient pas des bois traité pain
qui ont des résines oui et oui et puis
et puis des résineux aussi qu'ils sont
plus polluants que d'autres donc des
bois très secs des bois adapté au
chauffage au bois
et puis ne pas
enfin une chose c'est ne pas allumer son
feu par en dessous comme tout le monde
le fait puisque quand on allume son feu
par le dessous la chaleur va faire
dégager des composés organiques volatils
par le bois qui est au dessus qui ne
brûle pas alors que à feu de bois ça
s'allume par le dessus et le foyer
descend progressivement c'est comme ça
qu'on diminue la production de polluants
par un chauffage au bois de façon toute
simple est tout bête c'est toujours très
répandu cette pratique de chauffage au
bois olivier blanc oui paradoxalement à
l'impression si le cac soit larter
occasionnels dans l'impression que c'est
quelque chose d'assez marginal
en fait ça ne l'est pas alors ça ne
l'est pas donc par exemple des vallées
montagneuses comme la vallée de chamonix
où là il ya un vrai problème à régulier
de chauffage au bois et qui induit une
pollution massive et des pics de
pollution très très très lourd mais
c'est aussi le cas en zone urbaine dense
par exemple à paris et en périphérie
en hiver on estime que jusqu'à 50 % des
particules qu'on observe dans un pic de
pollution viennent du chauffage au bois
c'est énorme c'est encore une fois c'est
un peu contre intuitif mais voilà c'est
la science alors le chauffage au bois
est utilisé j'imagine aussi par des
personnes qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens de se chauffer on n'est pas
toujours vertueux en terme d'écologie
quand on n'a pas beaucoup d'argent on
l'a vu à fessenheim ces personnes qui
manifestaient avec des bonnets rouges on
s'en souvient la fameuse taxe carbone le
mouvement était parti de là comment
est-ce qu'on peut concilier je m'adresse
à tous les deux d'ailleurs comment
est-ce qu'on peut concilier écologie et
un faible revenu
c'est assez compliqué de concilier
écologie ee est faible revenu bien sûr
parce que le jeu direct le système
social s'est développé autour des
déplacements en voiture autour de
chauffage autant faire on a conçu un
système un mode de vie qui était pas
qu'il n'allait pas du tout dans ce
sens-là dire qu'on a créé des banlieues
à distance des villes et on a obligé les
gens à circuler en voiture pour aller au
travail pour aller d'un point à un autre
on n'a pas pris en compte le problème
des déplacements et des déplacements non
polluant pour les populations qui se
retrouvent dans l'obligation
d'utiliser des voitures pour pour rouler
donc de polluer et puis effectivement le
chauffage le chauffage au bois on n'a
pas pris la dimension de l'effet
polluants du chauffage au bois qu'on
connaît depuis depuis longtemps depuis
toujours et rien n'a été fait il aurait
fallu s'en préoccuper plutôt et aussi
améliorer l'isolation des habitats est
ce qu'on n'a pas fait ce que l'on
commence un peu à faire mais surtout en
ville et pas justement chez les
populations périurbaines et rurales qui
sont les moins favorisés le coût de
l'électricité par exemple avec la
fermeture des usines nucléaires il va
augmenter ou pas mécaniquement pas
forcément tout dépend comment on va
substituer l'énergie nucléaire y'a pas
d'après on a fermé on ne sait pas par
contre aujourd'hui par exemple s'ils ont
une vielle 17 auteurs si on prend si on
considère le prix de l'énergie solaire
par exemple photovoltaïque
actuellement le coût de l'énergie a
fallu prix de revient de l'énergie
photovoltaïque est inférieur au prix de
revient de l'énergie nucléaire dans
l'électricité nucléaire
donc on peut on pourra parfaitement
substituer le le nucléaire par autre
chose à des coups tout à fait acceptable
et baryton constituerait on pourra enfin
aujourd'hui on a confiance climatique il
ya urgence non par toujours au futur
mais on n'a pas fait on n'a pas fait
parce qu'il ya eu aucune vision globale
sur le sujet depuis longtemps
il nicolas malleval il n'y a pas de
volonté politique pour vous non je pense
que une volonté politique se traduirait
par des gestes forts au niveau des aides
d'être que ce soit économique ont parlé
des populations qu'on condé faible
revenu tout simplement donc si on veut
qu'un moment ces populations puissent
agir à leur échelle faut forcément
forcément les aider à et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ne voit pas ça de la
part de la part de la classe politique
donc ce serait quoi sous forme de
subvention pour inciter à changer ça
peut être ce genre de fonctions qui sont
mises en place relativement faible par
rapport à la voiture
je pense que là aussi on est loin des
réalités on veut si on veut vraiment
changer le problème dans sa globalité
faut des gestes un peu plus fort vous en
tant que jeune est ce que l'écologie on
le voit avec tous les mouvements actuels
qui se multiplient il ya beaucoup de
plus en plus de manifestations
aujourd'hui c'est les jeunes qui
reprennent cette question selon vous est
ce que c'est une question de génération
cc je sais pas si c'est une question de
génération en tout cas c'est vrai qu'il
ne fasse une prise de conscience de
l'homme de la part de ma génération au
niveau de tout ce qu'un environnement et
problèmes écologiques donc je pense que
c'est une bonne chose et que ça peut ça
peut effectivement faire avancer les
choses dans le futur un futur proche et
espérons le
on le voit ces greta solberg qui portent
évidemment cette cause
elle fait avancer elle fait avancer les
choses olivier blond selon vous
regrettez solberg très clairement elle à
elle a déclenché un électro choc
mondiale une prise de conscience
qui étaient déjà là mais qui était
réservé peut-être aux militants aux gens
qui sont déjà un petit peu au courant
grâce à elle elle se répand elle se
répand comme une traînée de poudre
j'espère et le problème c'est que encore
une fois
maintenant qu'on a pris conscience du
problème il faut trouver les solutions
et ça ben voila cela reste encore très
opaque et même alors c'est vrai que
c'est ce que c'est et critique que les
personnes peuvent lui faire c'est
qu'elle porte un discours certes fort
sauf que derrière où sont les vraies
solutions en tout cas pour parvenir à
régler et adopter des pratiques plus
vertueuse emmanuel macron il ya eu
l'idée de faire une convention citoyenne
avec 150 français tirés au sort pour
plancher justement sur des solutions
concrètes au quotidien avec une notion
de justice sociale
l'idée de faire cette réunion avec 150
français gilles gilles dixsaut vous
pensez que c'est ça peut être une
solution
c'est une solution à condition d'avoir
la connaissance technique derrière c'est
à dire voilà il suffit pas de dire yaka
et encore faut-il que l'on est une colle
et que les personnes en question on
puisse leur offrir toute la connaissance
technique et scientifique qui permettent
de dire voilà ce que l'on peut faire
c'est parce que l'arrière dialogue entre
les français qui ne sont pas forcément
des experts en la matière et des
spécialistes qui répondent alors qu'ils
aient des spécialistes qui répondent à
leurs questions mais qui est
suffisamment de connaissances en termes
aussi bien de pollution que de
l'évolution climatique pour ne pas
partir dans de mauvaises directions vous
choisir les bons experts alors comment
vouloir le dire les experts avec tout ça
peut être aussi contradictoires donc oui
mais en fait aujourd'hui il ya un
consensus de dire on est tous au courant
qu'il ya un changement climatique qu'il
ya des problèmes de pollution que les
premières esquisses de confiance les
consciences changements climatiques
parce que certains disent qu'ils sont
pas forcément d'accord ils sont 100 %
d'accord sur dingue
après que sur le disque non non ils sont
100 % d'accord après sur quel est le la
cause exacte du petit me connaît ici ça
oui mais qu'elle est dure aux agressions
la cause ils sont pas forcément non sur
la cause globale mais après sur les
petits mécanismes de détails
ils peuvent se discuter c'est des
scientifiques mais aujourd'hui il ya un
consensus qui est absolu et tous les
gens qui pensent ou qui font croire
qu'il n'y a pas de consensus se trompe
ou sont de man intense par des
climato-sceptiques voilà en fait ça
s'est passé
c'était vraiment c'est les années 2000
ils sont moins en moins voilà ils sont
derrière aujourd'hui on est tous je
pense à peu près
conscient il ya un consensus absolu sur
le le l'analyse
maintenant encore une fois il faut faire
des propositions et moi je trouve que le
le mouvement des gilet jaune qui a été
si important pour la france
eh bien il porte à un hyper cette cause
là aussi lors de cette cause là puisque
m'est avis qu'on les a on les a montrés
du doigt en ce sont eux qui utilisent
alors leur véhicule finalement émises on
paie donc et je pense qu'il porte à la
possibilité justement d'unifier un
mouvement écologiste est un mouvement
social
c'est avec eux qu'il faut discuter il
faut de discuter et c'est j'espère qu'on
arrivera à trouver justement une
écologie qui soit pas punitive qui soit
sociale je pense que c'est possible et
donc ces mesures qui seront proposés
d'ici à fin avril je crois devront être
validés
devant le parlement et peut-être soumise
à référendum gilles dixsaut pour vous
c'est la bonne façon ça va soumettre à
un référendum
un problème purement technique ça me
paraît pas forcément la meilleure
solution parce que personne n'était
experts et percer les gens vont voter en
fonction de leur ressenti d'un sujet qui
ne connaissent pas scientifiquement et
techniquement
donc je vois mal l'intérêt d'un
référendum dans un cas comme celui là
sauf un alter et social pour dire il
faut faire avancer les choses mais
comment cet objectif d'atteindre 40 % de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
2030 c'est le seul qu'on connaisse
véritablement est ce qu'il est ce qu'il
est fiable et pourquoi est-il
inatteignable olivier blanc il nous
reste deux minutes
je pense qu'il ya un à un un aspect sur
lequel on peut vraiment changer les
choses c'est la mobilité et notamment
tout ce qui est autour de la voiture la
voiture c'est presque 50% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre avec justement
le laissant seul carburant et on est en
train de vivre une révolution
technologique complètement folle entre
la voiture autonome
les voitures électriques les systèmes de
vtc et rasta il se passe énormément de
choses dans dix ans je pense que on
pourra dire au revoir à la voiture
thermique et ça ça représente un enjeu
absolument majeur pour la santé des
citoyens notamment en zone urbaine et
aussi pour le climat et le problème
c'est peut-être les lobbys y ait encore
qui freinent gilles dixsaut oui enfin
les lobbys freine parce qu'ils ont
besoin d'eux ils n'ont pas une vision à
terre mais ils ont besoin de voir à leur
court terme mais il faut voir une chose
qui s'est produite récemment ce sont les
grèves au mois de décembre et dans paris
les gens ont ressorti leurs vélos ils
ont racheté des vélos et beaucoup
toujours peut pas le faire vous en
convenu sans doute mais beaucoup de
personnes qui avaient ressorti des vélos
se sont rendus compte que finalement
c'était le moyen de transport le plus
rapide dans paris et ces personnes ont
continué à rouler à vélo donc ces grèves
ont été un moteur pour le développement
des mobilités dit 12 dans paris et ça va
continuer mais on la vit uniquement dans
d'autres villes on
le principal moyen de locomotion merci
beaucoup on va passer aux résultats de
notre sondage à présent
[Musique]
et comme toujours dans pôle it mag on
fait un sondage sur nos réseaux sociaux
sur une question à déterminer convention
citoyenne on en parlait tout à l'heure
faut-il à un référendum pour décider des
mesures de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et bien vous avez la réponse
oui à 82% non à 18% donc les français
veulent quand même avoir leur mot à dire
sur cette question et sur ces mesures
climatiques qui ont mis beaucoup de
français dans la rue
voilà pour ce résultat un commentaire le
problème est technique et il faut il
faudra aussi des solutions techniques
derrière et pas seulement des solutions
politiques et pas trop couteuse pour il
faut que les gens votent mais il faut
surtout que les gens agissent et chacun
peut faire des choses et prendre son
vélo ou consommer autrement tellement et
on a on a une marge de manoeuvre
on peut voter avec notre carte bleue
avait je pense que ça montre ça montre
vraiment une prise de conscience de la
part de l'ensemble des citoyens à de la
peau le matin voilà exactement de la
problématique liée à l'environnement et
ça je crois que ça fait consensus
oui oui mais du coup c'est c1 c'est
vraiment une
c'est donc la sphère du siècle comme
disait emmanuel macron début de cette
émission merci beaucoup le combat du
siècle merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
à ce débat c'est la fin de deux pôles it
mag
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
au printemps il verra t-on équipements
et le cas sera en morceaux rouge et il
prendra ton âme
et puis le fait qu'il a qui est il
[Musique]